well isn't that odd okay we watched the
medical dramas we played the games but
now it's time to take a look at one of
the most
successful animated series of all time
the simpsons to give a huge thank you to
thrive market for sponsoring this video
[Music]
why are they shocking everybody even in
the cartoons they take it from the
medical dramas and they're shocking
everybody chest compressions if they're
hard to stop and they're not breathing
and my man's going more
more well we can't fix his heart but we
can tell you exactly how damaged it is
what an age we live in it's classic in
medicine where we don't have all the
solutions and people right away start
saying
oh medicine sucks well how come we don't
have this maybe you're just a doctor
that doesn't know what the cure to this
problem is
no the human body is very complex and
while we know a lot about it there's
still a lot more left to learn
homer this is a new body fat analysis
test i start your jiggling
and measure how long it takes to stop
caliper test weightless pool tests for
body fat percentage
punch in the gut test in the simpsons mr
simpson
i'm afraid you have a crayon lodged in
your brain
there's a crayon in my brain
but i've had thousands of head x-rays
how come no one ever noticed it before
oh i can answer that you see whenever i
pick up an x-ray i always hold it like
this
my thumb must have covered up the crayon
when you look at an x-ray you have to
look at many things
including the issue at hand so a person
has shortness of breath you want to look
at the lungs you also want to look at
the surrounding structures because the
last thing you want to do is look at an
x-ray to see if the patient has a
pneumonia
and missed a cancer that's growing in
their humerus or on their rib
or on their clavicle this place seems
even nicer than the male clinic
male clinic eh
should we slice them diagonally or just
cut off the crust
why is it called the mayo clinic it's
gotta be because there was a doctor that
started
with the last name mayo it has nothing
to do with mayonnaise founders
charles and william mayo look at that
it's like i went to medical school and
all let's take a second and talk thrive
market
as you know my mission has always been
that you live your happiest and
healthiest life and thrive markets goal
is for you to do that
in an affordable easy fashion you're
able to log on
online save some serious dough members
on average save 32 dollars per
order and when you go online it saves
time because it organizes everything
whatever diet you follow whatever values
you have
paleo keto vegan you just click on it
right there on the website
and it groups all the foods all the
groceries right there for you
it makes it so much easier to make
healthy choices recently
one of my favorite snacks on thrive
market has been the dried seaweed snacks
don't know why i've just been absolutely
obsessed but even if that isn't for you
they have thousands of other products
and it's great value because if your
order is over 49
it ships free from a zero waste
warehouse and they're carbon neutral
so it's like good for you good for the
environment good for your wallet and
they have multiple membership options
for you to choose from
to figure out what's right for you for
me the 12-month deal at five bucks a
month is just a no-brainer and look if
you say to yourself but 12 months is a
long time to commit
guess what 30 days risk-free cancel if
you don't like it
boom look at that and the link is down
below it's literally down below and
you're gonna save 25
this is it the deal's right there for
you all right let's get back to some
simpsons
this whole morning has been wonderful
too wonderful
there's actually a really adorable video
of like a doctor who does this whole
like
show for kids with the needle to get
them excited about it and then like fake
injects himself and then injects the
child and then they don't even feel the
pain because there's so much going on
for kids who are able to reason somewhat
i try and talk to them
as if they're adults i bargain with them
and i say i'm gonna give you
you know this really cool pillow and
they're like why do we want a pillow
that looks like you and i'm like true
and i get them uh
something else that is furry and cute
and soft like bear or i give them
stickers of their favorite shows and
they're like oh that's awesome
what are we doing today i'm like well
today you're gonna get a vaccine a shot
here's why
blah blah blah they're like okay that
sounds fair you gave me a sticker and a
weird pillow so you must be nice i give
them a quick shot i'm very gentle we're
very good with it
my nurses are amazing and then they
leave happy hibbert money making
organization
is that what hmo stands for this whole
time i can provide every medical service
you'll ever need under
one roof rub a palm full of this
medicated salve into your scalp every
half an hour
keep him away from open flames and
pregnant women yeah they should help
those fallen arches
enjoy hmm throat looks a little red
i better spray it oh my god this is my
favorite skit ever and i think it has
less to do with hmos but in general the
fact that people in our society have
grown up with this theory
inside their head that they need to see
a specialist in order to stay healthy
and it's so not true because specialists
oftentimes deal with really complex
cases
they treat things a little bit more
aggressively than your family medicine
or your primary care doctor would please
don't think you need to see a specialist
for everything because
a that will happen b many things will go
away on their own and you don't need to
spend a whole ton of money to see a
specialist in order for that to happen
and c your primary care doctor is well
versed in solving all these
problems and not only are we well versed
in solving them we know you best
because we have an existing relationship
now doctor i want you to test me for
everything
every disease on this chart
fine we'll just start by drawing some
blood
well isn't that odd okay i'm gonna hit
simpsons hard with the medical
inaccuracies we do not
stab patients with a syringe and have it
come out the other side of their arm
and be like oh i guess it's not working
we do not just
check for a bunch of diseases when you
come in for a checkup
part of that is figuring out what
diseases we can actually screen for
there are some like cancers what
diseases we can prevent we could also
look at what risks you face
so get this a patient comes in doesn't
have liver disease but they talk to me
honestly we have a good conversation it
finds out
they're drinking a bottle and a half of
vodka a day it's a lot but
some people do do this we have a
conversation about hey what can we do to
prevent them from drinking and driving
what we can do
for them preventing themselves causing
harm in other ways themselves when they
are inebriated how can
we get them to cut down the amount that
they're drinking so they can stay
healthier longer
look at how much i've affected their
lifespan the progression of disease
simply by having a good conversation
that's what you should expect from a
doctor when you go in for a physical
and if you get anything less than that
please look for a second opinion mr
burns i'm afraid you are the sickest man
in the united states
you have everything you mean i have
pneumonia yes juvenile diabetes yeah
hysterical pregnancy uh
a little bit yes you also have several
diseases that have just been discovered
first of all how does he have juvenile
diabetes he's not
if juvenile age this sounds like bad
news
well you'd think so but all of your
diseases are in perfect balance
here's the door to your body you see and
these are oversized novelty germs uh
that's influenza that's bronchitis and
this
cute little cuttlebug is pancreatic
cancer here's what happens when they all
try to get through the door at once
move it shout ahead we call it three
stooges syndrome
no if you have a lot of diseases it's
not
better than having less diseases also if
you're a good doctor and a lot of tests
come up positive
you need to start looking for a cause
that perhaps
ties in all of these diseases together i
don't just say hey you got a bunch of
diseases
deuces there's a crazy man with a
scalpel in er
he's demanding to see a quack
[Music]
hi everybody now tell dr nick where is
the trouble
i met g i got ants in my pants i'm
discombobulated
give me a call my chip slow down sir
you're going to give yourself skin
failure
what is skin fail i think skin failure
is just when your skin just gives up and
starts slothing off
stephen johnson syndrome
insert the retractor and crank it until
the ribs swing open like a rusty
drawbridge
no blood silly but truth to it we do
watch videos on procedures all the time
and that's a good thing
you want your doctor up to date and
seeing the procedure before they do it
even if they've done it multiple times
that little refresher goes a long long
way
and you know where we do a lot of it
youtube your doctor watches youtube
before they perform surgeries on you
that's the truth these gloves came free
with my toilet brush
usually you have someone help you with
the gloves have the package open because
remember the
inside of the package is sterile but the
outside is not so there's a specific way
you actually have to put the gloves on
to make sure that you're keeping sterile
what the hell is that that's something
you don't want to hear from your surgeon
that
and oops i know i'm supposed to cut
something but what
and where the mask is not part of the
sterile field so if you make contact
with your mask right away you have to
leave change
gloves re-scrub in and do the whole
process all over again so my man is not
sterile no more dr nick riviera
remember me well if it is my old friend
mr mccraig
with a leg for an arm and a non-far leg
the only question i have after watching
that is what is that doctor's specialty
dr nick what do you do simpsons all in
all
does a great job of teaching you
medicine albeit satirically but as
you've seen with the onion episodes in
the past
i don't mind a little satire let's give
a huge thank you again to thrive market
for sponsoring this video
don't forget to sign up down below and
save 25 today and speaking of the onion
check out
my onion review here and my saturday
night live medical skit reviews
which one are you cooking which one are
you enjoying and as always stay happy
and healthy
you